how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mcu and today
we have some very
very big marvel cinematic universe news
concerning the hawkeye series
and kate bishop it seems like haley
steinfeld has been officially cast
as kate bishop in the upcoming hawkeye
disney plus series so i'll break down
the whole report in this video but if
you're new be sure to subscribe to stay
up to date on all things relating to the
mcu
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a scarlet
witch
funko pop all you have to do to enter
subscribe to my channel like the video
and leave a comment down below
so this morning it was reported by the
illuminerty.com
they have reported several things that
have ended up coming true like hulk
appearing in she-hulk which is now
confirmed to be happening and
christian bale being cast as the main
villain of thor
love and thunder which has since been
confirmed so a pretty
reputable source and this morning they
reported that there was a
99 chance that haley seinfeld is going
to play kate bishop
in the mcu they reported this morning
that on the cast
listing for the disney plus show haley
steinfeld
is listed as kate bishop however this
morning when they reported it they did
say that it was only
99 sure haley steinfeld is listed
as kate bishop but she hadn't signed a
contract yet
however since then things have gone from
99
to 100 as it has been reported
that marvel studios has their kate
bishop officially and
hailey steinfeld has officially signed
the contract to play
kate bishop and the mcu in the upcoming
hawkeye series and of course
future projects hopefully as well this
is really big news as everybody pretty
much
wanted hayley steinfeld for the role of
kate bishop
as far as looks are concerned and
physical capability she certainly fits
the bill
and we may even get a first look at her
as kate bishop
relatively soon as we have some
production news today as well
according to the illuminati.com
production of the hawkeye series is
hoping to ramp back
up in atlanta georgia this october so
once production
and filming starts we can expect some
leaked photos and maybe even some
special announcements from marvel
studios themselves
announcing haley steinfeld as kate
bishop the new hawkeye in the mcu
and maybe they could even release some
promo art to go along with it as well
the rumor that haley steinfeld was
in the talks to play kate bishop in the
mcu has been going on for a very long
time now since last year
but the rumor is finally confirmed haley
steinfeld is now
a part of the marvel cinematic universe
as kate bishop who is going to go on
in the mcu to become the new hawkeye so
her future is long and seemingly bright
for the marvel cinematic universe kevin
feige has already mentioned that the
characters from the disney plus shows
will appear
in the films so if there's a young
avengers happening or a new avengers
happening we can probably count on
seeing haley steinfeld as kate bishop in
those movies
castling is officially going on right
now for the hawkeye series but one thing
we do know is that jeremy renner is
returning as hawkeye
and haley steinfeld is now officially
kate bishop let me know what you think
about this news in the comments down
below are you excited that haley
steinfeld is going to be playing kate
bishop and the mcu
let me know down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe to stay up
to date on all things relating to the
mcu for live updates you can follow me
on twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof
you